now what you're going to see next miss
Donna Shu you will learn how to find
cube roots of larger numbers that is up
to six digits ah come on don't worry and
how long do you think you will take to
find the cube root of a large number
if you focus hard for the next couple of
minutes you will be able to find the
cube roots of large numbers in just five
seconds yes you heard me right five
seconds is all you will take to solve
the cube roots of large numbers let's
see a couple of examples assume we want
to find the cube root of 2197 now to get
the answer in five seconds there are two
things you need to know first we need to
know the cubes of numbers from 1 to 10
by heart here's the tables of cubes of
numbers from 1 to 10 in the first column
we have the numbers and in the second
column we have the cubes of those
numbers 1 cubed is 1 2 cubed is 8 3
cubed is 27 and so on second we should
know that 4 4 5 and 6 digit numbers the
cube roots will always be 2 digits long
since 2197 has four digits its cube root
will also be two digits long that's it
only these two things cubes of numbers
from 1 to 10 and the fact that large
numbers which are 4 5 or 6 digits long
we'll have cube roots which are exactly
2 digits long so let's move on look at
this table for a moment and think is
there anything that stands out pause the
video and think for a moment this is
what you should have observed look at
all the units digits of the numbers in
the cubes column they are all different
from each other all numbers from 0 to 9
are covered 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and 9
knowing this fact will
help you understand the first step in
our method okay now we're all set to go
the first step of our method is to look
at the unit's digit of the number the
unit's digit of 2197 is 7 so we look at
our table in the cubes column we look
for a number which has its unit's digit
as 7 it's this 127 so we take the number
from the first column corresponding to
it and write it in the unit's place of
the answer the number corresponding to
27 is 3 so we write 3 here so the first
step directly gave us the unit's digit
of the answer remember the answer is the
cube root of 2197 the next step is
interesting we ignored three digits from
the right of the number so we ignore 197
for the moment and look at the number
that remains it's 2 this number is very
crucial we check where 2 is placed in
the cubes column that is we check the
position of the remaining numbers in the
cubes column in the cubes column the
number 2 lies between 1 and 8 between
these two numbers that means it is
placed between 1 cubed and 2 cubed we
basically looked at the corresponding
number column the last step is very
important now that we know where it is
placed we choose the lower number in the
corresponding number column
the lure of one and two is one that's it
this is your tens digit so cube root of
2197 is 13 remember we always choose
numbers from the first column which is
the numbers column to write the digits
of our answer three was chosen from here
and one was chosen from here
this looks really long at the first look
but with practice trust me he'll be able
to solve it in five seconds now let's
solve another problem so that you
understand better say we want to find
the cube root of 195 one one two this
number is six digits long and hence its
cube root will be two digits long
remember cube roots of large numbers
which have four five or six digits will
always be two digits long now let's see
the unit's digit of the number it's two
in the cubes column we look for a number
which has its units digit - yes
it's 512 and the corresponding number in
the numbers column is eight so we write
a eight in the unit's place of the
answer now we ignore three digits from
the right that is one one two and what
remains is 195 now where is 195 placed
in the cubes column of the table it is
placed between 125 and
216 that is it is placed between 5 cubed
and 6 cubed so from the numbers column
we choose the lower number among 5 & 6
it is 5 and we write this number in the
tens place of the answer
hence the cube root of 195,000 112 is 58
with good practice you will be able to
solve this in five seconds and remember
that this method is a shortcut and
cannot be used to solve questions in
your exams you may use this method
purely to verify your answers
[Music]